okay
next game with this fm becker
so try to reach the king's indian not
sure if he
lets me
no he goes for
a quiet english setup
this is a line i played ages ago when i
still regularly
employed the king's indian i always
thought that
black should be okay somehow
the center is not bad
he's playing really quickly
okay
what now
d4 he will get e4
this doesn't look good
what if i play e4 myself e4
d takes e4 dc4
knight c495 this is an idea
interesting let's try this
at least it makes sense to
try to get counter play in the center
when he's putting all his pieces on the
the queen side okay
yeah i need to
if i take now he also needs to attend
to the bishop so he cannot even
recapture
it needs to go queen to b2 i guess
what about knight g4 in this position
knight g4
the idea of playing
queen a5 for insta queen f6
somehow i like this move i know i'm not
not entirely sure about its value but
it looks right in this position
somehow
queen siwon
i guess he just wants to retreat
maybe this one h4
on the cards
yeah but now now i have e5
and d3
a squares for the knight
okay what now simply take
of course i could simply take on b2 it
wouldn't be a bad move but
it looks a little bit strange
let's go let's go there
try to weaken the king position more
yeah but i'm not sure
well where is he going
if i take now on b2
now queen f5
maybe the knight b6 i see
okay i need to go back
time warning
hmm
how does he avoid to lose material now
the g7 bishop is a monster
hmm
it's really strange what did i what did
i do wrong
it looked like a fantastic position
ah shame this was really a great
position i think
check
it's still still a draw
i think but 8 seconds
is not not very much
of course
i just blended the rook and he doesn't
take it okay
okay this is a piece
this must have been a great position
yeah computer gives it is just winning
of course i can just take c3 because of
the back rank
oh
i can and and not queen c3 why didn't i
take this
oh my what what to miss
queen c3 simply
yeah sometimes you really have to ask
yourself if that's everything
zero right in your head jam
what a joke what a joke okay